pasamos a hablar con nuestro invitado
del día porque Venezuela está a un paso
de tener una ley para regular las
organizaciones no gubernamentales el
martes la asamblea nacional aprobó en
una primera discusión la propuesta que
presentó Dios dado cabello el
considerado número dos del chavismo la
Norma prohibiría que las ongs realicen
actividades políticas o cualquier acción
que desestabilice al país mientras el
gobierno defiende el proyecto las
organizaciones responden que la
intención del oficialismo es eliminar la
mayor cantidad de ongs para hablar del
tema nos acompaña Gabriela aguada
directora de la ong caleidoscopio humano
en Venezuela Gracias por estar con
nosotros y bienvenida aquí a France 24
el contenido del llamado proyecto de ley
del financiamiento y funcionamiento de
las organizaciones No gubernamentales
todavía no ha sido presentado a los
ciudadanos Pero qué se conoce hasta
ahora y que tanto cabe dentro la palabra
prohibir la realización de actividades
políticas
Sí muchísimas gracias por la invitación
bueno debemos tomar
entente desde hace varias varios años
desde el gobierno nacional efectivamente
el contenido no se ha publicado no ha
sido publicado Incluso se ha tratado de
averiguar de indagar con
gente afecta al gobierno con periodistas
de hecho
del del de la misma del mismo sistema
del Estado para
indagar que Cuál es el contenido de la
Ley Sin embargo tenemos que recordar que
esto no es una una medida aislada ya que
el año pasado A mediados de mayo estas
esta misma asamblea nacional también
trató de desempolvar lo que lo que fue
la ley de cooperación que hablaba
justamente
lo que tiene que ver con las medidas que
incluyen la divulgación de información
sobre el financiamiento de
organizaciones no gubernamentales la lo
que tiene que ver con el personal
información del personal de las ong Y en
este sentido sabemos que lo que se
quiere es tener control del
financiamiento e impedir que las ong
puedan de alguna forma seguir trabajando
a favor de los Derechos Humanos en
Venezuela Gabriela y usted mencionó
precisamente la ley de cooperación
internacional que se iba a discutir en
mayo de 2022 pero que finalmente el
parlamento no la discutió Qué
diferencias hay entre esta ley de
cooperación y el nuevo proyecto para
regular a las ongs
precisamente no sabemos
no sabemos Cuál es la diferencia porque
la ley no ha sido publicada no se habla
de ningún artículo en concreto
solamente lo que se ha conocido fue esta
exposición durante la discusión del de
esta ley verdad el día 25 de enero en en
la sesión de la asamblea solamente hubo
un discurso estigmatizante La amenaza de
una lista además de sesenta
organizaciones eh solamente si habló que
las ong están vinculadas a partidos
políticos y que de alguna forma estaban
esta ley estaba siendo presentada para
impedir
digamos algunas acciones terroristas
algunas amenazas contra el estado no se
habló de ningún artículo en específico
no se habló el contenido de la ley
solamente se estigma y se discriminó y
esto es un poco lo las exigencias que
hace la sociedad civil porque no sabemos
qué Cuál es el contenido de la misma
pero sí sabemos que el discurso
estigmatizante y amenazante continúa en
una dependencia del estado como en la
asamblea nacional y en ese discurso de
la presentación del proyecto de ley como
usted lo mencionó Dios dado cabello dijo
que ya tenía una lista inicial de 62
organizaciones a las que se le aplicaría
inicialmente esta norma en caso tal de
aprobarse usted dice que hay una
estigmatización detrás de estas
organizaciones qué Argumenta el chavismo
De qué están haciendo estas ongs en el
país
Sí justamente
en este discurso donde se estigmatiza se
nombra a varias ongs una ong como provea
que digamos es la que tiene mayor
trayectoria en Venezuela Y que además
atiende a Víctimas de de violencia de
estado no que ha estado constantemente
siendo combativa a través de la de las
denuncias que se han hecho en organismos
internacionales
y justamente el el discurso
estigmatizante va aislado en en lo que
tiene que ver con las digamos las la
las relaciones que tienen con los
partidos políticos el recibir
financiamiento para supuestamente hacer
acciones que de alguna forma agiten o
estén en contra del gobierno es decir se
está criminalizando a las ong
independientemente
de el trabajo que hagan Por recibir
financiamiento supuestamente para
desestabilizar el gobierno y en esta
persecución como usted lo llama contra
las ongs qué va a pasar con los reportes
que estas organizaciones producían por
ejemplo ellos han publicado datos sobre
la inflación sobre los contagios y las
muertes del covid 19 qué va a pasar
entonces con estos informes se quedará
Venezuela sin esta información
bien de aprobarse este proyecto de ley
la sociedad el mundo debe estar alerta
sobre todo porque se tendría primero que
cumplir con medidas abusivas o enfrentar
procesos penales u otra de las
características que pudo
señalar que tenía el proyecto de ley
verdad fue fue justamente las medidas
que incluyen la prohibición de
divulgación de
de violaciones de Derechos Humanos que
las ong tendrían que también divulgar
información sobre su financiamiento la
prohibición incluso de recibir
financiamiento de Estados Unidos no ha
mencionado
otros países pero específicamente
Estados Unidos por el tema de
supuestamente estar
en entrar en actividades de terrorismo
actividades que quiere que vean que
tengan que ver con el imp de de la de
todas las relaciones del gobierno
violarían también los derechos de
asociación a privacidad
las víctimas los datos de las víctimas
también estarían expuesto de aprobarse
esta ley y también expondría a a quienes
de alguna forma trabajan en en las ong o
hacen este trabajo que que justamente de
denuncia de documentación y que ha
podido de alguna forma tener cifra eso
eso es importantísimo entenderlo en
Venezuela no existe cifra de ningún tipo
no solamente en materia de salud como
fue con el covid 19 sino también cifras
de lo que tiene que ver con los derechos
económicos sociales culturales y
ambientales lo que tiene que ver con la
situación humanitaria que atraviesa
Venezuela y que las ong han venido
haciendo un trabajo de hormiga que
que en en la mayoría es la atención que
debe tener el estado hacia las personas
que trabajan con que tienen violaciones
de Derechos Humanos